this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app do you
want to get paid five dollars and also
give five dollars to charity do you want
to buy and sell Bitcoin instantly or get
your paycheck deposited right to the app
well then download this cash app it's
the number one finance app in the App
Store and we'll talk a little bit more
about it later on in the show download
the free cash app for iOS or Android now
[Music]
we're doing it it's episode 56 right
episode 56 of congratulations and we're
here and you know gonna say it again
never thought we'd be here but we're
here spent the last week in LA I'm check
this out we're in the one fire shirt
you'll be able to see it on the on the
video podcast but I'm wearing the one
fire shirt and you can pick that up at
crystally accom
now there was a hair draped on my
shoulder here that obviously fell out of
my head now every time I wear a white
shirt do I see multiple hairs that wind
up on my shoulder yes does that mean I'm
going bald yeah it means my hair is
thinning
does it stress me out yeah is it the
only thing that someone needs to be
stressed out about as a man yeah
looks like yes it does and does it yes
now is okay no it's okay but you know
what we're getting older and we're doing
it and we'll see we'll see what happens
we'll see how much we'll see one that
when the thinning stops right when the
thinning stops sounds like a [ __ ]
some Danielle Steel book but the one
fire shirts are limited there are only a
few left
follow the leader tour we got it let me
tell you right now Denver is almost sold
out it's a two thousand seater it's been
on sale for a few days it's almost out
now my bragging and you know perhaps you
don't know you did the math but the deal
is is it's going to sell out so get if
you
if you are a real baby and a real fan
then go get the tickets now okay because
it's you know Orlando's filling up
they're all they're almost a lot some of
them are almost gone so you know I don't
want to hear oh I couldn't didn't didn't
get it in time and this and that
couldn't hear it anyway
but whatever go to the chris chris
d'elia calm sea I'm also announcing more
cities so you don't have to be like oh
man you're not coming to [ __ ] Atlanta
I'm coming wherever I just imagine
cities but um so yeah that's what's up I
think I'm on the good doctor tonight I'm
not sure if it's not tonight it's the
next week so yeah do we all feel good
about ourselves babies is it a good we
it was it a good week do we all feel
[ __ ] good and positive man do we all
feel good about ourselves because we're
talking about how good Black Panther is
D do we all feel good white people
are you happy you congratulating
yourselves and and making it making it
about your guilt you massaging each
other are you saying dude I saw this
post it was like oh man finally Marvel
did something right
congratulations that lives up to the to
the hype a black pant their best movie
yet dude a white guy said this you just
you feel guilty okay you feel guilty I
haven't seen black panther yet so I'm
definitely talking about a turn like I
do on this podcast because I don't know
[ __ ] however white people stop givin
minorities attaboys stop saying good job
buddy
you [ __ ] guys are racist you are
racist you're racist okay
that's plain and simple stop [ __ ]
given minorities attaboys this isn't
Little League a movies good if a movies
good I haven't seen it I'm sure it's
good
I'm sure it's cool and let me tell you
something man the fact that like you
know little like black like black
children can now see this movie and be
like oh we get to be superheroes now too
that's [ __ ] awesome you know this is
not another movie about [ __ ] slavery
or the black people portraying black
people as the help and that's great and
that that is good and that's good and it
should be done and and it should've been
done a long time ago but let's stop
pretending like Black Panthers gone with
the [ __ ] wind
huh let's stop pray dude are we talking
about Black Panther or Schindler's List
dude these you these people these white
people are poison dude they are
pretending they are there you say Oh
black the pillars are good movies like
oh [ __ ] great movie Oh finally Marvel
does it with a good movie you're [ __ ]
giving attaboys we're not wearing
diapers dude you're making it seem like
like black people need [ __ ] your
congratulations and your because they
can't do it by themselves this [ __ ]
pisses me off dude it's so annoying dude
I don't know I'm right about this okay
like if there was a tweet that was what
the [ __ ] was it
this lady tweeted it this is the most
ridiculous [ __ ] I sent it in the group
text it's probably pretty far down there
because we send so many [ __ ]
screenshots and [ __ ] here it is oh wait
no I'm here it is here it is here it is
so I carefully did this is by Ella de
Walla Emily lac de Walla a white girl
with a short haircut of course so I
carefully did not buy Black Panther
tickets for opening weekend because I
did not want to be the white person
sucking black joy out of the theater
what's the appropriate date for me to
buy tickets his next weekend okay and it
wasn't a joke she was being for real I
wrote back hey black people aren't
[ __ ] special needs children what the
[ __ ] is this stupid racist [ __ ] now I
have to buy all the tickets and no one
gets to go I hope you're happy
dude whoa what are you doing what what
are you doing
it's a [ __ ] Marvel movie about a
superhero you doin imagine her Oh
go ahead go ahead black people it's your
movie it racist you're guilty what you
do in your life that you feel guilty
that you gotta give up your seat to a
black person to watch [ __ ] black
movie oh when do when is it an
appropriate time for me to go and I'm
able to watch the movie huh oh the
second it comes out why people are so
people while white people I guess are so
racist that they don't even [ __ ]
realize that they're doing it
every one so far
they were saying they say as you get
older you get more racist because you
[ __ ] just want to be near your own
like retirement communities are all like
white people or they're all black people
or all Asian people and that's just how
it is because of [ __ ] it's all based
on tribes and [ __ ] and like you don't
you just want to be around people like
you
I guess what if that's our nature
there's nothing you can't get away you
can't get away from that if I'm 90 and
want to chill with some white people I
can't help dad can't get away
it doesn't mean you hate another type of
person but dude
imagine giving up your seat so a person
of another race could sit down and watch
a movie about that that where there is
another where those that race is
portrayed imagine sir would you like to
sit down I don't want to ruin your fun
hey are you [ __ ] are you serious are
you for are they for are they for do
they [ __ ] their pants nah
are they for your making it
worse you know white chicks with short
haircuts you can be dangerous all right
with [ __ ] red ass glasses you know
and like short hair and red ass glasses
and a backpack you dangerous I don't I
don't know
look Black Panther I'm sure is a good
movie I'm sure it's a good Marvel movie
let's just stop pretending like it's
[ __ ] you know what do you call it
Serpico there's some [ __ ] I don't know
that's enough of that though
daddy got hot right there didn't mean to
get so hot but also speaking of hot a
guy I started we're developing a show
with YouTube red
it's not called zoinks and one of the
reasons why I'm doing it is because they
[ __ ] canceled ads on Logan Paul [ __ ]
and so it's like dude you know what
that's cool you know how I've been
talking about him and how [ __ ]
[ __ ] and shitty that guy is and you
know what okay but because of that now
here's the deal because of that now
who's got a [ __ ] youtube red show bro
you Kaizen rats bro you filming dead
people who got a youtube red show now
baby good probably cancel being a second
but it's okay cuz I still got it for the
meantime little much yeah you 22 when
I'm 37 and this is sad but [ __ ] it
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's the end of the end and then at
the end then at the end it's like this
when he does this how hilarious it would
be if he beat the [ __ ] out of me but
yeah dude
that's how it's gonna be from now on
we're doing it the babies come with me
man we're doing it all right we're doing
it do you think I'm joking about this
cult thing a little bit unless you're
really common unless you're really
common [ __ ] it
well you know that part in the end then
Nellie song just kidding Alyssa go and
do it was that [ __ ] that is hot in
here
just kidding let's go and do it like
that was maybe the best line in all of
the 2000s hip hop's
just kidding Alyssa gonna do it Nellie
dude and Nellie put a bandaid on his
[ __ ] face and no reason I'm just
kidding like JC
Alyssa going Dewey I'm just kidding like
Jason so stupid
it's Jason Kidd right not kidding it
just kidding like Jason even though it's
just kidding I added kidding but anyway
listen I'm doing [ __ ] that dude
[Music]
s harsh harsh dude I remember the first
time I heard hit him up
I was driving on [ __ ] Foothill
Boulevard and locked in the LA cañada
California swipe and I [ __ ] heard the
the part where he just goes like this
this is sad the first line I ain't got
no [ __ ] friends
it's what [ __ ] your [ __ ] you fat
[ __ ] shrewd imagine
hey let's invite to Park over I don't
he's always I [ __ ] he [ __ ] us he
[ __ ] he [ __ ] our [ __ ] and he doesn't
care dude he doesn't really have any
friends he said it listen listen dude
[Music]
right yeah and that was he did that to
[ __ ] Ted
just kidding like Jason um so uh kind of
got my dog he's here and they're just
chillin they love chillin they love
being near me dude sometimes when I put
him outside it's cold here in LA I'll
put him outside and I got a window on
the door and it [ __ ] in there shaking
cuz it's so cold and I feel bad but
sometimes I don't feel bad and sometimes
I'm very German about it and I'm just
like you forced out there until you
could [ __ ] on piss but yeah I realize my
dogs are like almost seven now that's
crazy and they're still hiring people
say that your keys like my buddy you had
a has York had a Yorkie growing I had
your keys growing up and he was like are
they chill out after a few years nothing
don't these [ __ ] things were so
[ __ ] come here but mutters come here
they're so [ __ ] spazzy and [ __ ] come
here grab him by the neck Peters gonna
get mad whatever dude that's what their
mommies do I'm their mommy dude I'm your
[ __ ] mommy dude I know the other ones
jealous
let me live a little bit watch this
movie last night dude we had a bad we
had bad movie night and we watched this
movie it was called uh well it was
called blood money but then we realized
that they changed the title was on
Amazon Prime it's called blood money
blood money and then it was called The
Killers edge and I don't know if they
but if they changed it or what but dude
there were these movies that were made
in like 1991 they were like they're like
a bunch of them and there's by this
production company I don't know what but
they'll have the same actors in the man
[ __ ] we didn't realize till after we saw
it but dude this movie called blood
money ah I mean it's so 91 dude it's
unbelievable it actually looks like it's
more in the 80s it was one of those
movies like you know if you don't have a
good budget if you don't have a good
budget it's Russian if you don't have a
budget like it seems like the movies are
made a lot longer ago this thing was
made in 1991 some of the shots look like
they're in [ __ ] 1950 but it was with
this guy named Robert this door weirdest
last name this door you know and he
plays the bad guy he has this thing is
it a deformity or what is it disease
what in condition I don't know but it's
called cherub ism and it makes your jaw
look super manly basically you look like
American Dad and but look I'm up Robert
the star he's one of those guys were you
like hit you you saw in 90 you see a
movie about him in 1991 and then you
know that he died early you know like
you can't like seeing a guy that was
alive like that 20 years ago you know oh
[ __ ] this guy died and he was like 52
you know what I'm talking about you see
guys like that but you know what's weird
is the cherub ISM that he got cherub ism
is a condition that makes your jaw
really big and and honestly like it
looks a lot but it's it's a tourism as a
disorder characterized by abnormal bone
tissue in the lower part of the face
beginning and early childhood
both the lower jaw the man
and the upper jaw the maxilla I mean
rappers what up is mandible the maxilla
become enlarged as bone is replaced with
painless just like gross so these guys
like have big jaws but they look kind of
manly dude not saying I'd want it but
like and I'm sure there's different
cases of it but raah oh well yeah there
definitely are but Roberts door it just
looks kind of [ __ ] it look kind of
like manly and [ __ ] but if that's okay
to say also is that kind of [ __ ] up to
call it cherub ISM you know like it's
like it is isn't it cherub ISM you're
saying it's like a cherub it's like
calling something [ __ ] it's a
constant ition donkey ism like I don't
want to be compared to a [ __ ] [ __ ]
baby angel I don't know also why is it
called cherub ism you don't look like a
cherub on it are you gonna grow wings
too you grow wings - that's why I forgot
I forgot Robert his daughter had wings
as well but acting in this movie is so
bad it's like under so many times and
there's one dude in it that looks so
much like turning Tony Curtis we thought
it was Tony Curtis the whole way - and
his name in the movie is Tony how
working up Tony Curtis now how is that
not the guy that was in that movie last
night dude dude it wasn't huh that's
unbelievable I've never seen someone
look more like someone else then Tony
Curtis does then there's one of the bad
guys in this movie [ __ ] blood money
or the killers edge how come in the 90s
they made all these [ __ ] movies with
the most Vegas titles ever vaguest
titles of all time dude they never it
would be like The Killers edge Blood
Money revenge
they make a movie just called like okay
one fire is really trying to look up the
guy and it can't do it we don't even
know what I don't know but there's like
75 volt there's also 75 movie name Blood
Money since then you know Gino denty is
that him
look at that [ __ ] name a Gino denty
whoever do you know Dante is owes people
money you can't have a named Gino Dante
and not Oh people money that's him right
Gino denty is Tony Curtis dude hey I'm
[ __ ] Gino denty Gino don t is such a
name where you either owe money or are
owed money
there's no way Gino than he ever has
that amount of money that he has hey
guys I'm into I'm into a guy who for 50
50 K you know it is guy owes me 40 grand
but you know I'll get I'll level it out
no you won't why you don't believe me
now cuz your name is Gino don t they
take it easy these movies that they make
that that they just like and it was
amazing in the 90s because you could
just make independent movies and then
sell him somewhere and now the movies
that they make they make even more and
they just stream them it's like the Wild
West now you just [ __ ] stream them and
you can just find like Amazon Prime or
like or like Netflix or Hulu they all
have them but we're gonna have bad movie
night like once every few weeks and
we're gonna do that we were talking
about turning it into a show that'd be
fun just like green screen us and
watching the movie I don't know but
anyway Bob
I guess I don't know what else to talk
about what if I if I just did a 20
minute podcast how mad would the babies
be but you'd have to be with me you'd
have to understand and be like listen
you know he did it because he had to and
you know it was all good let's not
[ __ ] push him you know I mean this
shows that the Comedy Store were [ __ ]
awesome I wanna do it was [ __ ] insane
the other night on Friday or Saturday
night
it was Chappelle was there Chris Rock
Marlon Wayans and just so many [ __ ]
comedians that were just there that were
like super [ __ ] big and all Palin
around everyone was in a good mood
I saw I saw Chris Rock special dude I
[ __ ] loved Chris Rock special
I never I've never seen a full special
four years I put it on I just wanted to
check it out and i watch the whole
[ __ ] thing man he is that guy I think
pound for pound is just I mean the skill
set he has and then also just how funny
is how much he obviously respects
stand-up and how hard he obviously works
I mean that guy will come into the
Comedy Store and do a bit that's like
he's obviously working out and then
you'll see it later and it'll just be
like boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
the guy is amazing and he's had it's his
first special in 10 years he it's like
that special Tamborine uh reminded me
why he's Chris Rock I always loved him
but this [ __ ] special man he was just
it's so good it's so [ __ ] good man it
made me happy for comedy you know
because a lot of people are getting
specials there's a lot of them out there
especially on Netflix and you know you
know HBO does a lot of them and Comedy
Central does a bunch but this guy just
reminded you of what a great comedian is
that works on his [ __ ] I mean it was
just great man I was watching it in awe
as a comedian and God I mean this
constantly changes for me who my
favorite comedian is at the moment but
like he
he's he's he he's the best I mean he's
just the best God that guy is [ __ ]
good and I know obviously he's good but
Jesus if I was like as a comedian that
[ __ ] his killer that [ __ ] is so good it
also like sometimes some people are so
good you're just like oh [ __ ] I want to
give up that's good though it's
inspiring you know it's inspiring to be
- for that I guess but Chappelle was in
the belly room doing a two shows last
weekend working on new material this guy
[ __ ] so much material this guy's so
prolific how does he do it do it it's
incredible I mean I put out a special
once every year and a half two years but
this guy oh we put out four in two
months you know this guy's just like I
need another twenty million dollars
let's make a special imagine you could
be like that butters is gonna have a
special bottles I have a special
not really just drop them fat [ __ ]
uh-huh I don't know man honestly
sometimes I'm here's the thing when we
talk on this podcast when I talk on this
podcast just imagine me on the phone
with you and you're just chilling on
your bed and you're on your belly and
you're sticking your back feet up and
you're a little your little girl even if
you're a boy you're a guy you're a
little girl now and you're in your
[ __ ] bit little bedroom and it's all
pink around around and you're on speaker
and I'm on speakerphone and you don't
really talk back but you're a little
girl
there's your cutie [ __ ] and you're on
your tummy that's what this [ __ ]
podcast is man and we're having a
conversation only you don't really get
to talk down much for [ __ ] sake I got
to here's how here's how I am and here's
how old I am
two humidifiers got to I got to I
plugged them both in and I play them
when I [ __ ] go when I go to bed and
they moist the [ __ ] up then I wake up
I'm a little less moist the next day and
when I forget I wake up and I'm as dry
as a [ __ ] mummy I've had chapped lips
my opener told me the other day
he's like you've had chapped lips you
gotta get rid of dude I've had chapped
lips since [ __ ] March of 2012 I
always have chapped lips how about this
I always have chapped lips and a [ __ ]
and I mean I was thinking about aging
the other day let me do it let me do
this [ __ ] [ __ ] first and then and
then I'll and then I'll do it okay
Square cash if you haven't heard we're
switching to the cash app we already did
it I pay people with the cash shop I pay
them back it's the simplest way to do it
you pay back friends family you pay back
wedding guests anyone
you spent yep you can give stuff people
you can pay for you know food medication
this way for your friends dropping some
stuff off sending receiving money is
totally free and fast and most payments
can be deposited directly into your bank
account in just a few seconds did you
know that the cash app lets you do way
more than that now you can even buy and
sell Bitcoin instantly you get your
paycheck deposited right to the app pull
money out of the ATM with free custom
cash card or use it to spend anywhere
you like you won't really find a more
useful finance app out there and I'm
telling you I use it all the time and of
course when you download the cash app
five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to the times up Legal
Defense Fund it's a great it's great up
I I switched over and used it I used to
use other ones and then when this one
came out it's just easy you can just
text basically text money to your
friends that have the account so
download the free cash app or iOS or
Android now it's the future you got to
do it me undies you've heard me talk
about me undies and you know that I'm a
big believer in their product I have
them on right now they're the perfect
balance of comfortable fit every month
they have new and exciting prints and
they arrive at your door in a fun bag
who doesn't want something with a fun
bag on it the best underwear because
your situation doesn't get all bunched
up I don't know what it's like for a
girl but it's very comfortable
you know what these you know what these
Wonderware feel like when you put them
on like you have a girlfriend or a
boyfriend
that's how comfy you feel feels good in
your heart my undies uses lensing micro
modo
in their underwear it's a substan ibly
sourced naturally soft fiber that starts
with beech wood trees and ends with the
most amazing fabric you've ever
experienced the results have been
downright dreamy 100% satisfaction
guaranteed me undies guarantees you will
love their undies or your money back
me Indies has a great offer for my
listeners I'm a first-time purchasers
when you purchase enemy undies you get
20% off and free shipping the undies is
so sure you'll love their underwear they
offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee if
you don't love your first pair you get a
full refund
that's a no-brainer get 20% off the most
comfortable undies you will ever put on
to get you 20% off first pair free
shipping and 100% satisfaction
guaranteed go to my undies comm /
Congrats
that's me undies dot-com / Congrats but
yeah I'm getting older and like I got
back pain okay chapped lips nose is like
the Sahara Desert hairs fallen out
hey ha I'm starting to look like the
goddamn Crypt Keeper I know what where
I'm headed future wise I'm going to look
like Christopher Lloyd that's it I'm
gonna [ __ ] buy a white lab coat and
just walk around and people are gonna be
like ah [ __ ] I get it now I'm gonna look
like Christopher [ __ ] Lloyd when I
get older he's the guy in Back to the
Future for those of you that don't know
how come Christopher Lloyd has been 70
for 40 years oh you know how to go back
to the future the only time he was young
and cuckoo was in Cuckoo's Nest
right and then he played what's his name
in the ATA's family he's actually kind
of handsome though look at that look at
him on taxi on the left in the red
background no it doesn't i handsome
there right there it's kind of
cool-looking I'm just saying that cuz I
hope coz that's definitely me [ __ ] I
gotta go Marty come on Marty god I would
hate being known as a guy for just one
word like no matter what you did
like I don't know but you were good and
back to the future 70 years ago put on a
lab coat I I don't know I have a movie
coming out in a little bit called half
magic I think it's coming out next week
I'm gonna do Corolla next week
yeah it's next week are you coming up in
a few days I think this week I think
actually yeah I don't know I don't what
else to talk about dude if you know what
I realized something though and I
thought of this and I don't know if this
is gonna make sense but here's how
dramatic I am this is this is this is I
always I was like I had a bit my first
special how girls were like I was like
I'm really not into all that drama and
like that means that you're dramatic you
[ __ ] if you're talking about you're not
into drama you're dramatic okay that's
it if you're talking about you're not
dramatic you're dramatic congratulations
people always talk about what they are
not they think that they are how they
are and they are not how they are they
are they are they are not how they are
they are how they are not this is what I
was talking about a few podcasts ago and
I couldn't feel the feeling of what I
was trying to talk about about how
people always say what they what they're
not like when you watch the jinx that
guy wanted to get caught he was like I
kill he went to the bathroom I started
talking about how I was like they're
gonna catch me and he was he had the
microphone on him and he was wired but
like when somebody talks about like oh
I'm not scared they're scared that's why
when you're when when the girls like hey
just so you know we're not having sex it
means that they want to people we
bringing it up for we bringing it up for
a sign mind right but here's how
dramatic I am if I was hit in the head
and I was alone if something fell on my
head and and I fell down and it knocked
me down but I didn't get knocked out I
was just hurting on the ground uh and I
and I fell down
I would pretend I was knocked out for a
few minutes even though nobody is around
that's that's how dramatic I am I
realized that if something hit me in the
head I would fall down and I go long and
I go home and I'd hit the ground and I
would just stay there for a few minutes
knowing I wasn't knocked out but still
trying to pretend and believe that I was
knocked out and then like seven minutes
later I'd get up and go like even though
I don't need to if nobody was running if
people were around I wouldn't do it cuz
I wouldn't want to scare him but and
then and then I would I wouldn't like
pretend I wouldn't tell people I got
knocked out but that would just be like
from me
that's how dramatic I am I'm dramatic
when it comes to being when it was alone
like that I would [ __ ] for sure do
that
and I think you know I'm like I've done
it like when I was a kid I actually
realized I I tripped I I tripped and I
fell and my dog was outside and I fell
right next to the window and I fell and
I stayed there for like a few minutes
with my eyes closed and my dog was
watching me and I stayed there with my
eyes closed pretending that I was
knocked out for until my dog was like
pawing out the door a few minutes later
and started crying and then I felt bad
and I was like ah [ __ ] and I got up and
I was like all Cody come here it's okay
like what a waste of [ __ ] time you
know I cannot believe I did that [ __ ]
but I did do that [ __ ] little kids are
funny huh one time
one time when I was a kid I
I grabbed my my cousin and he was so he
was younger than me he was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] he must've been like five or six or
seven and and I grabbed him and he said
get off of me you smell like your house
it's weird and that [ __ ] was like oh wow
that's crazy that you could be six or
seven and have that much emotional
intelligence or you know and be like oh
I was like this guy's kind of a genius
huh kids are [ __ ] [ __ ] don't huh
I used to be so scared when I was a kid
of everything I'd run into my parents
room and be like hey oh yeah what's up
maybe like what I'd be like I was scared
like there's nothing to be scared about
I'm gonna one time my dad would be like
what are you even scared about I'd say
and I said and I said already said
everything birds he's a bird so I was
like yeah I'm just scared I don't even
know what of oh man I was a knight I was
a lunatic when I was a kid
all I needed to see was one [ __ ]
image of Freddy Krueger and I was done
or Jason or Michael Myers even worse but
that pale white face dude [ __ ] that's
good to [ __ ] I mean my friend Kevin
Nelson would always dude oh I talked
about him before he was mom would always
let him watch [ __ ] raided our movies
even though he was nine and he would
have me watched a Freddy Krueger in his
basement his basement would be a half
carpeted and a half stone half like
[ __ ] granite how come that carpet was
harder than that [ __ ] but then end
and then rocks they put like a thin
layer of carpet over the [ __ ] stone
on the on the basement this is East
Kazaam East Coast [ __ ]
and then when you'd fall on it you'd
like break your hip but you'd be like ah
but it's carpet so it shouldn't hurt
that much and it hurt and they'd have
that [ __ ] TV that lays on the ground
remember that TV that laid on the ground
they don't really make those anymore
those ground TVs that are just too big
and heavy and they just have like they
make it look like they made a little
furniture because
just too big and clunky and shitty and
then you'd go to you have to get up to
change a channel and it would go come
come come when you change a channel and
they'd have that orange [ __ ] band
that would like show you what channel it
was on that bright orange thing my
grandma killed it with that TV dude I
would go to my grandma's house after my
grand grandfather died and it's a sad
and we would go and we would watch
[ __ ] hunter the TV show remember that
show one fire to remembers but dude
hunter the TV show and he was like an
ex-football player I think right and he
would he was it was basically just the
we were hunter man and the show was
probably bad it was SATs guys pretty
handsome here's actually real handsome
but he would like he and the and and he
was like a detective or something and we
would watch it and we would be me my
brother and my grandma in bed and we
would watch a [ __ ] she'd be like you
want to watch hunter and I'd be like
yeah okay and we what we watch hunter we
watch ago we watch Golden Girls and
Hunter that's where we watch
back-to-back Golden Girls and Hunter and
we would just fall asleep we would spend
the night at my grandma's house dude
that [ __ ] was bomb as [ __ ] man you know
what that was real love love feeling
love from a grandma man that's awesome
my mom would just drop us off and I
would never go into her basement you
know why cuz she had a [ __ ] taxidermy
stuff [ __ ] swordfish scared the [ __ ]
out of me everything in the basement was
[ __ ] creepy man I swear to God
you put a clown up on the on the top
level not not creepy at all
you put a clown on the [ __ ] upstairs
not bad you put the clown downstairs
over some carpeted stone that clowns
gonna [ __ ] you and molest you but we
will watch hunter and Golden Girls man I
love that show Golden Girls I was
[ __ ] nine I would watch that [ __ ] I
was eight me and my [ __ ]
five-year-old brother we watch Golden
Girls and I grab how would always be
like or my grandma would always be like
you know the one who plays their mom
actually younger than Bea Arthur and I'd
be like really she look so old she's
like I know but she's younger Wow
you couldn't [ __ ] look it up back
then you just had to trust your grandma
I'd be like could you google it she'd be
like what's that it wasn't invented yet
Bea Arthur Bea Arthur was the oldest one
apparently even though the mom was the
her mom was younger than her in the
movie or in the show Estelle Getty
that's what it was remembered stop her
my mom will shoot with [ __ ] Sylvester
Stallone stop her my mom will shoot the
movie with tanked dude
Sylvester Stallone and Estelle Getty yo
stop what my mom was shoot you I
remember this one part where he would
take a shower and just caught you
red-handed video of me been looking at
videos of me on fire right there in the
middle oh man caught me red-handed
this is my account how you logged into
my account dick he's locked it on my
account and I use everything that like
you suggested for me and it's a video of
me on lip sync battle it's hilarious
how's that go caught you red-handed and
it's me on fire still on fire exposed me
remember that song thank you for being a
friend wait have you heard the Andrew
gold version of it
dude this is the whitest song of all
time I think this guy wrote it ain't you
cold
the movies called intermission
he plays first of all this is the
whitest song of all time this is it it's
called big fat daddy um how many songs
start like this coming this guy wrote
the song at Golden Girls I think so many
sexual deviance is Anita breed little
girl like you I'm big fat daddy
the word fat is just like come on why
the fact that he wants to be fat is so
disrespectful dude I was thinking about
sex would be better for me if I was fat
I feel like sex would be better I've
talked about this with my friends if I
was a fat guy I would be more turned on
because and I think I think that it's a
[ __ ] up thing about me because I think
it would be like first of all it would
mean the girl would like me more I like
actually because it wouldn't be about
looks on my sign on the most handsome
guy in the world but I at least I'm thin
and I take care of myself you know and I
know I'm gonna look like Christopher
Lloyd later but I gotta get the I gotta
get married now so I [ __ ] can cuz I'm
gonna end up looking like [ __ ] I say
48 gigawatts or whatever but if I was
fat either it's two ways either I know
the girl would love me for me and
therefore I would have loving sex and
then I would be able to it would be
better because sex when you're loving
someone is way better it really really
is and I know I know I have a lot of
[ __ ] I know a lot of virgins listen
to this podcast and I just wanted to
tell you guys loving sex is better even
though also it's pretty cool to just be
humping but so there's that but then
here's another way it could also turn
you on if it's not and if it's just sex
then why is there girl doing it you know
like I got a fat ass belly and the girls
having sex anyway oh why she doing that
turns to cocktail in a weird way app I
shouldn't be admitting admitting this
but like thinking of a fat guy like a
super fat guy having sex it's like kind
of makes it like deviant you know like a
real fat guy with like a real hot chick
what's going on there right you see it
you've seen it right a really fat guy
with a really beautiful chick it's like
what's going on in your head yeah but
yeah okay sure money but besides money
if it it's happened also when it's not
money so what's that the deal with dad
what is that dude that's kind of weird
and DV and and deviant what's the word
deviant yeah I don't know I'm putting in
trouble I just you know it's okay to be
fat yeah it's okay to be fat it's
definitely okay to be fat if you're
humping it's better
I don't know something's weird cuz if
you think about porn like you don't like
if I'm watching porn which I don't I
really don't do that much I'm sorry to
disappoint you guys I want to be able to
tell you I do because I want to be able
to admit that and be raw and what you
see is what you get but I just don't but
if I'm watching I don't really want the
guy to be fit you know
if I'm watching porn I want the girl to
be attractive to me but I don't really
want the guy to be fit I don't really
care if he's got like a little weight on
him I'm like I cool cool cool it could
be me you guys know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about - oh what the [ __ ] is that
one fire just pulled up hogging sexual
practice hogging or sweat hogging refers
to the practice of groups of men who
target over with I'm overweight or obese
women sit disrespectful calling it
hogging - how is this even on Wikipedia
okay typically for sexual unlike fat
fetish fetishists men who participate in
hogging are not necessarily sexually
attracted to obese woman's body they aim
to take advantage of a female's
stereotypical low self-esteem oh the
worst people or to derive amusement for
themselves and their friends by engaging
in sexual activities with women who are
over it
oh the demons of the earth
come on how [ __ ] up do you have to be
as a man to do that yeah what happened
people just beat the [ __ ] out of you
every day in your life oh look criticism
hogging has been described as a form of
misogyny oh yeah really in this [ __ ] no
[ __ ]
I've never been like that when guys are
like yeah I had sex with her just for
this story like that some [ __ ] guys say
I've never been like that ever
I've never done it never would it's just
like what oh you had sex with a girl
that you didn't want to further story
hey man your life's boring go out and
get other stories you know you had to be
like yeah I had sex with a girl she
didn't wanna had to do it for the story
really what's the story you just told it
it's two seconds now what
yeah though just to you know impress
other terrible guys oh yeah yeah it was
classic really now you know it's classic
Something Wicked This Way Comes by Ray
Bradbury no it's not classic you had sex
with a [ __ ] plump chick ha
could you call it hogging Syd
disrespectful if you're happy who gives
a [ __ ]
honestly if you're happy you're
overweight if you're happy you're
underweight if you're happy you're
[ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] it's not uh
it's not up to anyone else right I guess
as long as you're not healthy because
then it's selfish right because if
you're gonna have a family and you're
just eating and [ __ ] and eating and and
you're gonna die soon and get cancer cuz
all the [ __ ] sugar dude how good I
can't I started eating snacks from
Trader Joe's dude hey snacks from Trader
Joe's what the [ __ ] did they put in
there I think they put [ __ ] drugs in
there dude they're so good and for some
reason you feel healthier eating snacks
from Trader Joe's even though it's not
it's not but you're like at Trader Joe's
look at it there's so many hippies here
um oh come on dude look at what one fire
pulled up this is terrible
I'm sure I'm glad I don't even know
about this yet now I guess I do look at
this look I just go up go up go up go I
want to read the part first of all it's
called this is a disclaimer this is
gross okay
Red Wings the expression to earn one's
Red Wings means to perform cunnilingus
on a menstruating partner the phrase is
a reference to menstrual blood stains in
the shape of a small birds wait yeah we
get it you know on yeah on your face you
get like red I don't even want to talk
about this but here's the part here's
the part that I liked that holders when
I started talk about it the slang term
originated among biker gangs yeah we
know
hey biker gangs you talk bad you talked
by that's locker room talk that's like
you're in the locker talk in the actual
locker and you're locked in
remember when Trump was like yeah I
grabbed her by the [ __ ] and he was like
that's a locker room talk that's not a
locker room talk man
this is locker room talk oh she's so hot
man oh I want to [ __ ] her so bad
that's locker room talk oh man she's so
hot
yeah but her sisters ha not that hot
yeah but she's hot that's locker room
talk this locker room talk ah dude this
is what a guy would say she's sucking my
dick man it was awesome this is a locker
room talk Hey you grab them by the puss
even when they don't want you to that's
vile talk that's criminal look at look
at I love how Wikipedia and then here's
no facesitting you don't need to
describe it it's in the title
facesitting also known as queening or
kinging is a who's making these [ __ ]
terms up hey babe
want a king what lay down hey babe want
a king yeah and I don't know what is it
lay down
wait are you gonna practice in with one
partner sits on or over the others face
typically to allow or force oral jeanna
genital or oral anal contact yeah I'm
gonna get sick we'll go up go up face
sitting right there face sitting using a
queening stool god these [ __ ]
products that they have at sex shops
sometimes special furniture is used such
as a queening stool or smother box Hey I
imagine honey
I bought ass mother box I want a divorce
hey honey I bought ass mother but it's
over no no no no no lay down see what
you do is you put this up on top of your
face and then I sit down and hey let's
just do regular horizontal sex wow those
are the people that design this mother
box you know see to hood it wikipedia'd
says see also teabagging oh yeah dude
tired of T an infomercial tired of tea
bagging your partner with no extra help
or way to sit down
don't your quads burn tired of having
them burn tired of waking up the next
day sore as hell no some other boxes try
the new smother dog
smother box easily portable bring it
with you slide it under the bed you know
how they always every infomercial slides
under the bed look at this [ __ ]
smother box dude we got to show this on
the video Jesus Christ I love every
informant by the way it's just a toilet
you know whoops sorry pissed oh hey this
stylist but if I sat on a smother box
the way the thing looks it would be so
[ __ ] sense-memory I would just [ __ ]
it's a toilet you'd sit and I'd [ __ ] and
I'd be like whoops sorry I forgot I'm
not used to some other boxes only
toilets but yeah every infomercial your
infomercial ain't it you ain't if you
don't have if you have work our
equipment and an infomercial and you
don't slide it under the bed it ain't
[ __ ]
they've better fold up and slide under
the bed and easily storable and they
slide it under the bed
put your smother box easel easily under
the sink fits easy all right we got an
elder today we're gonna announce the new
elder here we go grace at grace KR 26
complete true baby just look at her
Twitter page it basically exists for the
sole purpose of spreading the cult Thank
You grace I mean look at this girl she's
got all the shirts she's her picture is
of a my pillow a herd of my pillow got a
little picture of she's just great she's
a sweetheart look at her oh she's even
got the wand fire shirt like I do true
baby right there
oh that kind of [ __ ] makes me happy man
if I was a [ __ ] idiot I'd be like it
makes my heart smile you know how people
say that I'll fight you I want to do
some critters questions this
I love how some of these guys make me
laugh cuz it's like what kind of an
animal do you think I am look Alex
Kessler at Kessler underscore Alex how
do you feel when strangers tell you your
shoe is untied I mean it's literally
just somebody trying to help you you
know oh thanks what do you think I
should give these people do it like oh
yeah [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] him for trying
to help me as my shoe I'll tie it when I
want or untie when I don't want kind of
[ __ ] animal do you think I am nothing
scarier than the dis guy Andrews a gar
at Andrew underscore Sega have you seen
the new robot by Boston Dynamics it's a
dog that I mean we're dead every time I
see some [ __ ] like that I think weird
dad dude look at this [ __ ] thing
we're gonna show it Boston Dynamics
robot whoa dude this thing is scary new
dog light raw dog like robot from Boston
Dynamics that opens doors dude
thing would [ __ ] kill your mother
dude one robot open up the door for the
other robot so consider it until it
[ __ ] pins you down and uses its
robotic arm to literally intrude your
anus and there's nothing you can do
about it there's nothing you can do
about it you'd imagine getting [ __ ] by
a robot
you think getting raped by a human is
scary we're [ __ ]
Oh robot doing it you you know how
psychological it is how [ __ ] up
psychologically it would be to be like
oh I'm trying to tell this guy to stop
but he won't stop and he knows I want
him to stop how [ __ ] up would it be
when you're getting [ __ ] by a robot
you're telling a robot to stop and you
know robots don't even understand stop
diddling then then then what if that was
my PSA on NBC dude that's terrifying
this [ __ ] and they made it yellow
this is terrifying dude all you got to
do is put a [ __ ] gun on that on the
top we're [ __ ] that thing could get in
my house and just have one of those guns
that is it goes in the circle and just
goes yeah yeah and just [ __ ] one of
those like the in the in command or no
and what's the other one predator that's
the first time I saw yeah I just bullet
so hard that you don't even need so many
bullets that you don't even hear that
it's just yeah put that on top of that
[ __ ] robot doggie we're done we're
done we're done yeah and you know what
I'm gonna see that robot doggie coming
at me with that [ __ ] Gatling gun and
I'm gonna be like this alright alright
that's my [ __ ] thing everyone maybe
you might be like oh [ __ ] that this is
me alright fine [ __ ] it and I have a
newspaper I'm reading the newspaper and
I don't gonna read the newspaper but
that's what happens I had to go alright
then I just throw it up in the air okay
here we go
shoot me just don't [ __ ] me or [ __ ] [ __ ]
me after I and and then I'm dead
facedown and then the robot uses its
hand to anally penetrated
get dude we're done we're done dude we
are done you see that yellow robot we
are done I'm carrying jugs of water
around so I just pour it on that [ __ ]
thing in at short-circuits we're so
[ __ ] I was listening to this TED talk
and they were like look technology is
good and bad always you know and it will
you know eventually we'll be merging
with these kind of like robots and we'll
be half half human half robot cut type
people like we could think something and
then robots will move or some [ __ ] and I
guess that's good and bad because then
the you know look it's like it comes
down to this life will be easier on a
day-to-day on a daily basis but also war
will be way more terrible dude World War
1 when they made the gun when they made
the [ __ ] automatic guns
imagine how terrifying that was generals
in battle battle that used to [ __ ]
hold arms and be like and then all of a
sudden some guy came in with the first
gun and was just like and the first line
and the second line is stepping over the
foot what the [ __ ] is going on they're
stepping over the other dead bodies
and they're just dying all of them
getting mowed down dude every day
hundreds of thousands of people in World
War one were mowed the [ __ ] down these
people never saw these guns before do
you know how scary that is imagine
living in that time and not knowing
about these guns and then all of a
sudden that's as scary as now if [ __ ]
dragons came and we're fight we wouldn't
know what to do same thing we'd be like
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
or these yellow robot dogs they [ __ ] us
Ron they're [ __ ] the first line go
grabs the [ __ ] drum just [ __ ]
crushes it no no no pinning your arm
back [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of you that's
how it was in World War one that's just
as scary as it was because we didn't
know what these [ __ ] guns were must
Fox and there's just some [ __ ]
general with an eyepatch behind it all
just like hitting a button the [ __ ]
button [ __ ] them all I want total
domination ha ha ha
we can't shoot their yellow robots who
can try water that doesn't work it only
works in eighties movies oh [ __ ] ripping
heads off [ __ ] them you know dragons
that's as scary as it was at least it
was quick I guess Wow imagine what it
was like back then you got your little
[ __ ] muskets and you got a and then
[ __ ] clean it and then push the
bullet down some guy comes in just
basically with a robot a yellow robot
that [ __ ] you anally that's basically
what it was all right almost done here
at it's KB at Ryan Murray Ryan Murray
what do we think about standing desks
you know what I would have a standing
desk because I the sitting down thing is
bad for you man sitting down for [ __ ]
12 hours a day or however time time
sometimes people work for a long time
dude I would have a standing desk my
manager has a standing desk yeah no one
that said look there's a desk in there
you know tanning you know but uh yeah I
yeah I would get a desk or at least one
that you can adjust they have those that
you can adjust there's a infomercial and
you can fold it under your bed anyway
we'll go to that back to that one ah
Zack Crampton are you finding it harder
to keep politics out of your at politics
out of your act and the podcast in the
current political climate honestly yeah
it's so hard to not talk about politics
just because of how crazy and divisive
the world is and also it's just what's
going on you know it's like all of the
news is that it's like news used to be
about like Oh Britney it's Britney
Spears's birthday and now it's like Oh
Donald Trump said the n-word at a press
conference it's like what so yeah it is
really hard but also like I like being
silly man and it's hard to be silly
about that [ __ ] I mean you can but it's
always like it always feels like if
you're doing political comment
commentary or political humor you've got
to be making a point and [ __ ] which is
fine it's just I like to [ __ ] I like
to [ __ ] escape you know I like to be
I live in my own head I like to talk
about what the [ __ ] going on in my own
head that's why I like this podcast you
know I like to talk about robots [ __ ]
you against your will like so it's like
you know you got these [ __ ] but it's
like it's hard to it's it's hard to it's
not hard but it's like when when you are
that kind of person and then when things
happen where it's like all they're gonna
build a wall to keep Mexicans out it's
like okay okay I got to think about that
too because it's a responsible if I
don't you know alright
square square cache have you switched
yet download the free square cash app
enter rewards code congrats get five
dollars give five dollars - times up get
it for iOS or Android now and in the
meantime send me money on it nah I'm
kidding not a hook I got a tour going on
follow the leader
buy tickets on Chris D'Elia calm
Tallahassee Orlando Charleston
Pittsburgh Dayton Huntsville Nashville
Denver Boise Cleveland and more common
talk about something I'll talk about it
next time it's a good thing subscribe to
the YouTube channel and download the
Chris D'Elia app for iOS or Android I go
live on there and talk there a lot and
sometimes I show behind the scenes here
subscribe rate and review the show it
really helps us push our hold a little
bit further and I'm gonna be on the good
doctor coming up either this tonight or
Ornette or next week I don't remember
and half magic comes out I believe on
Friday which is a movie that I'm an in
selected theaters directed written and
directed by Heather Graham thanks for
listening babies guys are the best